mainstream media is also happy to
largely ignore the president's soaring
new approval rating they're also playing
down America's record-setting economy
the unemployment rate is now an
incredibly low three point nine percent
joining us now with more is counselor to
the president
Kellyanne Conway good evening Kellyanne
good evening thank you for having me and
congratulations on your bestseller book
amazing Thank You Kellyanne listen what
we heard when the the over the last
couple days was stunning enough but the
reaction by the press to sarah sanders
and the reaction by the press when they
are now saying that everyone close to
the president knows that he's not
well-liked mika brzezinski and the claim
that the president is not well by chris
matthews do they really think those
10,000 people cheering in pennsylvania
and wealth spare were stupid and
couldn't figure out if this president
were smart with the program or not with
the program well that's the thing judge
all across the country and i travel
frequently on behalf of the white house
and you see the president out on the
hustings quite a bit now he'll go to his
third rally this week tomorrow in Ohio
he was in Florida and Pennsylvania
already this week and he does that for a
very specific reason he takes the case
directly to the people cuts out the
middleman and let's face it the
middleman doesn't like it cuts out the
middleman when he communicates with all
of us at the very same time what's on
his mind at any given moment through his
vast social media platform cuts out the
middleman and I don't want to lose sight
of how much affection and appreciation
there is in this country for this
president and his policies people know
they feel and they're living exactly
what you just said a booming economy the
predictions were doomed
the reality is boom and people know it I
went through the crowd last night
Pennsylvania they are there because they
are appreciative of having options in
this job market they're appreciative of
having more money in their pockets and
their bank accounts it gives them
freedom and confidence in buoyancy and
it won't matter who tells them that
that's not the truth if they see it in
their 401 k's they see in their
paychecks they see it in their home
values the other thing is I know there's
a lot of hand-wringing about are the
media bias and this that me I mean is
the ocean wet but the fact is that the
bias of selectivity is the one that I've
been talking about now since the
campaign certain leads through the
transition administration and is this
you can look at bias coverage but I
think what's really harming America is
what I refer to as incomplete coverage
the omission of all of the stories that
are actually news you can use details
and facts and figures that people need
to know is American so the
administration and the media each have
vast platforms ours is much bigger
frankly which is probably also bought
bothering some of these other folks and
their readings and their revenues but we
have just a second I want to they're
just not doing that they're not doing it
but you know when you talk about what's
going on in this country I mean you
forget about the media that you know is
just totally focused against Donald
Trump and I want I want to ask you I
want to get an on another subject in a
minute but the animal spirits that are
going on the instincts in this country
with the economy when the president
talked about Valley Forge and the role
of steel in Pennsylvania I mean he is he
is integrating the two issues the
economy and you know a patriotism and I
thought it was just brilliant the way
you did it but I want I want to go on to
this woman with the New York Times is
going on the Editorial Board of the New
York Times Sarah Zhang you know most
journalists operate under the you know
the guidance of the editorial board and
this woman is antic anti-cop she's
anti-white she's anti men everything
that she said is explosive in her tweets
and yet
the New York Times is supporting her on
their editorial board so as the great
lady flipped her lid what are they doing
well it's a little shocking that the
bias with this particular writer would
be so flagrant and blatant I mean
usually they try to hide it a little bit
better I'm surprised she still has a job
only because you can't say on the one
hand she mean that this is an opinion
writer she's just expressing her opinion
on the other hand you and I can sit here
with hardly even thinking about and come
up with 12 15 20 instances where people
lost their jobs over as much or frankly
less than that less than that and
everyone knows it and I do want to shine
a light in case the viewers and the
listeners missed it on mark Caputo a
writer at Politico who I know years ago
I used to do polling for the Miami
Herald and and the Tampa Tribune at the
time I knew him years ago
in Florida as a reporting out reports
for Politico he referred to the Trump
supporters in Florida as if you put them
all together you would have a full set
of teeth he said that and then when
people attacked him and asked him to
retract that on social media
he said he doubled down on this at oh
did I hurt their feelings he called them
garbage garbage people and then he said
did I heard the garbage people's
feelings let me go get a fainting couch
you know how does his job so this is the
level of discourse and let me tell you
something not everybody in there in the
media is the same not every Indian that
every day stays the same right but there
is this visit there is this growing
sameness within what is covered and what
is excluded from the coverage that is
harming but it's just shocking to me
that these people still have a job in
what is called reporting it's not
shocking to me that the media have about
a 70% of prove awaiting theirs is going
down staying the same where the presence
is actually rising as you said and to
not cover the repatriation and the
vice-president I states Mike Pence
meeting our fallen heroes as their
remains came to Hawaii this week from
North Korea that is derelict of duty for
anybody who calls themselves a reporter
they should stop talking about this
omission
they're amazing the news is about
trashing the president and trashing the
people who elected him president and
that's dangerous but well we lived
through a campaign it won't work you
know what we prefer positive candidates
in this country since 1960 all the way
through 2016 with the exception of 1972
this electorate has always chosen the
presidential candidate they saw as more
positive let me have some istic I'm just
sunny so knowing what you know and all
the stances that we have and the
president first term historically is
party losses midterm what do you think
is gonna happen in 2018 you're the
pollster here well we know that you sure
we know the historic numbers we know
that Obama lost 63 seats that was a
shellacking Clinton lost 54 seats in
control of the house but they had also
taken actions that were outside the
mainstream they didn't give historic tax
cuts historic deregulation try to bring
peace in dark corners around the usually
coming into this president well I do I
do and I'll tell you I do we can't the
one thing that we're up against that we
cannot control our 42 Republican House
retirements that's devastating but this
is the president doesn't follow the
trends
he makes new trends he doesn't repeat
history he's made history and he will be
out there doing his level best as well
the vice president oh you can do this on
the beauty tree in the middle out there
all right Kelly absolutely I'm by the
way nobody's predicting nobody's
predicting 60 losses 60 seat losses have
you noticed they're not doing that and I
did well pick up in the Senate as well
and get through our cabin on the Supreme
Court thank you all right Kelly Ann you
got it all in